joining us now a man whose name you will
hear the commissioner recite early in
the process on thursday night oregon
tackle penn ace welcome in how are you
man good how are you good best word to
describe how you're feeling two days
from finding out your football future
excited uh it's been a long time coming
and uh just ready
you know i i am a big supporter of the
guys who chose not to play last year
there was so much uncertainty health
issues family issues take precedence
over football looking back on that how
hard of a decision was that for you to
not play football for a year
uh it was one of the toughest decisions
i had to make in my lifetime to sit out
from the game the thing that i love to
do it was hard and just like you said
ultimately what came down to the
decision just deciding on that was the
pac-12 cancelling their season
and the moment that happened i just had
to really weigh my options and see what
was on the table and go from there
yeah and you know in hindsight it's easy
to say well guys could have played
because you know it ended up not being
as bad the nfl got their season in but
at the time that was an excruciating
decision we didn't know how bad it was
going to be we didn't know who was going
to be safe who wasn't going to be safe
and people had to make prudent decisions
have you gotten any sense that there are
scouts that there are teams that look
differently at you because you made that
decision or have they been supportive
uh yeah they've been kind yeah they've
been supported i'd say uh not really
saying or questioning my character or
wonder on whether i love the game or not
so uh nothing like that
what do you say or what would you say to
anyone who would say the fact you didn't
play last year shows you don't love the
game
uh man uh
all i can say is i can show you better
that i can tell you and uh just weigh
all my opportunity and i'll show you
without a doubt at the moment i step in
between those lines with that helmet and
pads on uh you will see that this is not
just a game to me and so that's all i
gotta say
peacock the
platform that our show streams on has
all of the old wwe content i've been
watching a lot of wrestlemania you got
three brothers that play college
football so i got a wrestling question
you put four sewells in a ring for a
battle royal
who's left at the end
i'd say myself i think i'm coming out
talk uh it'd be a tough one a little bro
starting to get some sides to him
and then there's obviously older bro
that uh my two older brothers that got
more quickness and agile definitely more
condition uh not carrying as much weight
as i do but
coming down i think
uh i wanted more so
do you think they would they would be
able to to come together and have a deal
to gang up on you and throw you over the
ropes first and then they worry about
each other uh i hope not
i hope we're all just man on for
themselves we're all trying to
do it for
uh
the man in the mirror but if they try to
team up against me i'm gonna do my best
i'm trying to i'm trying to envision you
guys growing up give me give me the age
differences for the four brothers
man so it's about two
to three from my uh older sister down to
my
uh little brother so it's like my my
older sister she's
25 and then bro he's uh
23 and then
other bro 21 and me
20 and then uh
uh little bro 18.
so did you guys cost more growing up in
food or cost more in the stuff in the
house that had to be fixed because you
broke it rough bouncing we did break a
lot of things uh
mom and dad were not happy back on the
island
i'd say food still
because i was
i was really eating a lot
and then there's other three boys
playing football player doing the same
things i do so i eat a lot too and then
the only one that wasn't really
hurting the bill is probably my sister
my son was the biggest kid in his high
school small school
he wanted to be a full back wanted to be
a tight end wanted to carry the ball
played the line
it was always kind of a challenge to get
him to embrace that because he wanted
the ball in his hands from your
perspective what's the process of making
yourself love the game when you know
that you're never going to have the
object of the game in your hands and do
anything with the football
oh man
i fell in love with the position early
to be honest the moment got to the
states i knew
what the position was asked of and i
knew that again that spotlight just like
you you were talking about was gonna get
uh let go and then i wasn't gonna touch
the ball so without we'll go what goes
through my mind
is
uh
really
the brotherhood
that's all i think about as i do it for
the man next to me i put my body on the
line for them and so that they can
uh just like you said when they have the
ball in their hands do their things and
make them feel uh the way they feel when
they when they touch the rock so
if i could really make that i guess
process a lot more joy joyful and
exciting for them i'm gonna do it and
for me i love blocking so to really get
in somebody's chin and really uh move
them from point a to point b against
their will that's what i love to do
you prefer pass blocking or run blocking
run blocking a big man i don't like
going backwards i love to go forward and
create that momentum and uh yeah
what's your own preferred ideal spot on
an nfl line of scrimmage left tackle
right tackle or one of the guard
positions
a preferred i'd say left tackle uh but
i'm comfortable playing anywhere from
left tackle to guard to center so
what have you ever played center
no
uh haven't only snapped a couple times
but never really had a live rep i said
it
which nfl team did you follow growing up
penne
uh
a couple
but the one that kind of stuck out to me
was uh the alliance i was a big fan of
uh calvin johnson uh loves love seeing
them go up
get the ball and also the running back
they had at the time was jab at best
uh i would just use them and matted
because
my brother and i would have tournaments
and stuff like that and i love to use
the underdog so uh at the time there
they had those two and i'll just use
them against like my older brother or my
little brother
i see more and more mock giraffes that
have you going to the lions now
would you rather go as high as you
possibly can or are you thinking i'd be
willing to go a little bit lower if it's
a team whether it's alliance with
someone else that i'd like to play for
right
um
to be honest i'd like to hear my name
get called as early as possible
get eliminate all the stress and also
have a team
believe in me that i deserve to get
called early and uh
all the hard work i put in i feel like i
deserve it so
we know the first three guys are going
to be quarterbacks this year that's a
given when is the stress start to kick
in for you is it at pick number four
uh
yeah i would say i say right there and
then
uh hopefully right it stops right there
like nothing else i just get my name
called from four or five
and then after that
let's just hope i'm not in that position
to think about that
so when your old teammate justin herbert
from oregon says he'd like the chargers
to draft you hey you guys are number 13
sorry that's no no thank you not
interested in waiting around that long
i don't know if not 13 i'm not trying to
wait 13 long but if they move up somehow
and then in god's hands and
it is what it is and if a team wants me
they'll get me if they don't it's all
good just keep pushing
how hard is it for you to accept the
fact that this really is out of your
hands that your next chapter in your
life where you live where you work got
to pick your college don't get to pick
your team how do you process that
uncertainty and that reality that
there's nothing you can do to affect it
again it goes back to that uh my faith
and uh leaning on my mom about that
faith too just kind of just trusting uh
the plan and again just like you said
it's the first thing that's kind of out
of my hands i don't get to decide where
i go
and i just go wherever i wanted and uh
go from there so
leading up to this i was fortunate to
really decide on what where i go to high
school where i go to college so
it's not too bad to have the nfl
take it over from here
i just want to get to a team
work
and
live my dream
you've decided not to go to cleveland
for the draft you're going to
participate virtually help me set the
stage give me like a virtual reality
thing if i'm you on draft night what am
i going to see when i look out in the
room
um my family so we're going to have mom
and dad next to me on the couch and my
brothers either behind me or next to me
now my older sister sitting on her own
couch right next to mom and dad well mom
not gonna be the side so either uh on
mom's side or dad's side depending on
where she wants to sit
and uh
probably gonna have my aunt there in the
room and uh
they're in the kids too i'm gonna have
my niece in the building uh lonnie delay
uh so i might just have my family there
all seeing on the couch just kind of
chilling and also
having food on the table
in the background probably some pizza
huh and so
uh
actually about pizza
man uh finally got partnership with them
so shout out to pizza hut this one's
close to my heart because like it goes
back all the way to the island so i'll
have some pizza hut on the table we'll
eat some pepperoni pizza my favorite
cinnamon sticks so
uh yeah
they had pizza hut on the island used to
you and your brothers go hit the pizza
hut buffet they'd see you guys coming
they probably locked the doors i was a
little smaller back then so they didn't
really think too much of it but yeah my
my aunt was the manager there so uh it
was just easy and she's my favorite at
the time and i spent two like probably a
little too much time with with her
and so every chance i got to hang out
with her whether she was at work or not
she would always come home with with
pizza after i'm done playing outside or
some cinnamon sticks and uh
man it's it was one of my favorite meals
of the day and something i look forward
to when i was on the island
what's your usual pizza budget you know
i try to hold it at two pieces but that
that it never works how many do you do
you shoot for when it's pizza time man i
shoot for at least eight
at least
for me depending if the if the slices
are cut a little smaller then it might
go a little higher
but if the pieces are right
i'd say i'll finish a day off with a
minimum
you do you go you go thin crust do you
go the regular or do you do the pan
so
i i start off with regular but i do like
the pan though the the little squares uh
that's something i just got i just found
out about actually but yeah i just kind
of just throw it back to what i knew and
what i had on the island and i just
munched down
do you save room for the cinnamon sticks
or just like jello is there always room
for cinnamon sticks yeah
there's always room
you just eat as much pizza and then you
just take a little uh intermediate rest
i would say and then just kind of get
your second wind and then throw down
them cinnamon sticks
you got justin herbert was awesome last
year
why do you think he was able to come to
the nfl and just click as quickly as he
did no real prep got pressed into
service when tyrod taylor had some sort
of a reaction to
a pain killing injection and five
minutes later justin's out there and he
never looked back why do you think he
was able to be so good so quickly
uh because he's a real professional from
the moment i stepped on the campus at
oregon i knew that the way he carries
himself the way he goes about things the
way he prepares
he's just he was built for the nfl and
he was
it all started at oregon he practiced
that he he did that at oregon so when he
it was his time to go to the league and
really do his thing it was just kind of
second nature to him and it was easy it
came off naturally so i just say he's a
real professional about the way
he goes about things in the way of life
for him
you're regarded as the top offensive
lineman in the draft uh some would say
by far but there's criticism of everyone
i think that's part of the process do
you pay attention to the criticism and
is there one specific piece of it that
bugs you
um
i'm not a lie i do see it
it doesn't bother me no but obviously
everybody's on social media uh
and i i come across some
some uh led by up not by some opinions
and stuff like that but
uh no i just added on to the list of
motivation i had added on to the list of
uh proving people proving people wrong
and so
i just added in the back of my mind and
so when i crossed again going back to
when i crossed that field across the
line of play it's on
um i'm putting my body on the line again
because i haven't played in the year so
i'm not taking advantage of anything
else i'm coming with a lot of heart i'm
coming a lot of passion and i'm not i'm
not coming up short
what did you miss about football the
most last year
man just
putting on the helmet and pads and the
and to feel that
uh
to feel to hit somebody that's what i
miss the most uh to really get my stance
to come off the ball with violent
intentions to really impose my will on
somebody that's what i miss
ultimately well hey pane we appreciate
some of your time we know it's a busy
week can't wait to see
where you end up on thursday night and
it definitely will be thursday night
it'll be early thursday night so you can
get to bed after you eat all that pizza
hut
we appreciate you very much look forward
to talking to you once we know who
you're going to be playing for pal thank
you man appreciate the song
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports